heyo I'm Dierks Bentley and you're
watching certified country with Sophie -
I see
[Music]
welcome to certified country I am Sophia
Lacey today we're taking the show on the
road we're here in the gorgeous Crater
Lake National Park meeting up with
Dierks Bentley
now Dirk's is on a break from his what
the hell to her he is here to celebrate
the 101st birthday of the National Park
the biggest tours ever been on and most
fun we've had ever on the road and it's
been unbelievable play these big
amphitheatre is where I used to go and
open up for other people now they get a
chance to go out there and sell mountain
the show is right this give all my
energy away and I come out to a place
like this just recollect and reclaim all
the energy and store back up again so I
can go back out there and do my job the
best I can tell me about sharing your
love of the outdoors with your kids are
they adventurers they are yeah my kids
uh like any kids out there you know they
we live in a city live in Nashville
there's not there's a lot of great that
comes with that a lot of great things
about being a city but there's also you
know I want to raise like city slickers
you know I definitely it's important to
make sure they my kids get out and yeah
and you know have that same love of that
doors would I do know I got to ask you
about your beautiful accessible watch
some my daughter and I with matching uh
matching us watches here so you sir on
my mind when I'm on the road that's so
sweet do you keep it on all the time I -
I was gonna take it off those interviews
I thought it kind of weird wearing a
pink well ma'am just gonna no role so
your kids are they're getting so big
would you say your family's complete now
oh like having more kids yeah we're done
yeah I probably need to make it official
okay definitely not planning any more
kids three is like having a thousand
that's is it three kids or three dogs
it's yeah it's it's a lot of work do
they know dad's famous we never talk
about that stuff really you know I don't
have any records or gold plaques or
anything hanging my house you wouldn't
even know that I sing where do you keep
those up in the attic yes all probably
in the corner however have to go through
the change their filter I was like
that's pretty cool let's talk ask some
guitars lying around obviously and they
all went on place the piano and place
the fiddle Knox kind of he's like such
our arms we would drumset lying around
so um but they they love music they love
singing
[Music]
are you worried about them getting the
bug and wanting to get into the industry
or will you embrace that great question
I you know just encourage them to do
whatever just follow their hearts and
you never they do want to do music great
but trying to do this as a profession it
can be very tough yeah feel very lucky
to have made it there's so many so many
talented singers and songwriters out
there so just kind of courage them to
follow their bliss and just to chase
things down and live courageous lives
and go for stuff and support them no
matter what they they do solid advice
yeah we gotta talk about the music are
you working on the next project I just
started to work on it you started
listening a lot of songs writing a bunch
of songs you know little writer's
retreat next week actually out in
Colorado with some favorite writers and
I mean they get to get together for like
four days and just see what we can kind
of like get going thematically yeah I'm
really excited the next record this is
scary time you're gonna come up with you
gonna build a record out of nothing you
know you're trying to find an idea to
just start it on and he reads me on
nothing and then we gotta build a whole
new show up with all new stuff so it's
really exciting at the same time it's
kind of bittersweet to leave this other
chapters behind how does that work do
you start off with kind of a message
like what do I want to say at this point
in my life I really try to make records
that um they're like like a book you
know has it has a theme to it has it and
so I don't know if that's a sonic sound
or is a lyrical idea or is a bigger
theme so this next one I don't know you
know maybe we'll have somebody earth up
being out west and then in these
mountains and exploring of the outdoors
do you get more creative when you're out
here totally yeah go back to Nashville I
use it will pull my guitar go get out
the case I just kind of it's not will
feel inspired that much being home
what's your business right yeah it's
work but at the moment now here's some
more it's like I just actually like
tendons reached my guitar and started
playing stuff I know it's early in the
album process but can you give us any
sort of teaser on and what you're
feeling what your vibe is you know I
think a lot about just this year's one
of those years where you struggle so
hard to make it the ups and downs and
I've enjoyed all the ups and all the
down so you know but
like climbing a mountain or something
you know just trying to get to this spot
I feel like this year we got to it
you've been here but this year really
just felt real um so I know something
about that journey and not just
musically but also in life and in love
feels like it could be a theme
[Applause]
what is the first concert you ever
attended Bon Jovi skid-row 13 years old
first album you purchased I don't know
if a purchase Waylon Jennings uh just a
good old boys buy stuff in the first
little bit of vinyl I had song currently
spinning on repeat a buddy of mine who I
fly with my fellow co-pilot he loves
Justin Bieber he's listening a lot of
that song I would love to see you
covered Esposito yeah bluegrass thing
before yeah yeah uh-huh
make a great bluegrass version but it
those words are tough I see why Justin
has a hard time remember him in his own
show because it's a you only have to
know the language go sing those uh yeah
verses okay tell us one thing about
yourself that we've never guessed by
looking at you we already know your
pilot well I really enjoy cold water
okay my cold water plunges Tennant you
know spend like 15 minutes a day in a
nice no trashcan place if you weren't an
artist you'd probably be doing what the
fly yeah flying around a little like
small tail drag or a float plane and no
maybe taking people to remote places to
go fishing and trying to fish a little
myself the plane
[Music]
we usually wrap up every single episode
of certified country with my song picks
of the week I'm gonna let you do the
honors today okay well I love brothers
Osbourne my fault
only guilty
yeah they think their whole records
awesome another work about a new one
right now some exciting here that
Midland drinking problem is like just
[Music]
drinking
keep on talking
they call it problem
and then uh probably a heartache on the
dance floor John pardon I used that one
recently that's one of my favorites
certified country right here she knows
what she's thought that's my jam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I heard actually driving up here today
was pretty pretty appropriate since it's
about West - all right now Friday August
25th is the official 100 and first
birthday of the national parks to
celebrate they're having a fee free day
all across the country
so y'all can get out there and find your
Park in the meantime if you like what
you saw please hit like and subscribe
we'll see you right here again next
Friday